what advice did you give him when he
said he wanted to start fighting right
you know what I'm saying you can only do
so much if I'm going to be honest I
didn't I didn't know how I felt about
him fighting he started wrestling
when he saw the wrestling
I was really I was really proud of him
because you know
he started late just like me like when
he was 17. and um okay he's gonna do
something positive then
he wanted to start fighting and he
started hanging out with Antonio McKee
and I was like okay he he already chose
like the best coaching yeah with the
boys yeah yeah so I was like oh yeah go
ahead I'm
I'm just gonna step back and let him
Coach you and I just tell you some of
the things that worked for me yeah so
you try not to be overbearing right it's
tough man yeah I think that's what I
think that's what you where fathers mess
up a lot of times they they don't make
it fun for him and nowadays
they're like they're too much